my lips are bothering me hey what's
going on everybody for first we feast
I'm Sean Evans you're watching hot ones
the show with hot questions and even
hotter wings today I'm joined by Harley
Morenstein from Epic Meal Time what's
going on thank you so much for having me
and this is kind of a unique episode
because I don't know whose episode is
gonna come out first I don't know how
all that stuff is gonna work but we did
the old switcheroo so I did the Epic
Meal Time
handleit show and of course does you
have the hot ones guy on we made the
hottest damned ribs that you can
possibly make with the help of Megadeth
sauce so I'm walking in here sweating
I've got the cold sweats a little bit my
stomach's rumbling my lips are on fire
and I haven't even eaten a wing yet how
are you doing I have a headache and I'm
sick we had this earlier and like I just
almost got over it like I now I'm
certain that I'm not gonna barf
so like I'm good now good this might be
the best episode of hot ones ever it
might be the worst episode that one's
ever we don't really know I like you but
so far this has been like the worst day
for me of 2016 it's also I spent the day
with you same I like you too we're
already like friends I feel yeah but
we're putting each other through some
[ __ ] yeah people don't bond like this
don't people don't do this it's a shared
struggle and by the way if you're a hot
ones fan you're gonna love epic Meal
Time so when this episode is over shoot
over to Epic Meal Time subscribe if you
haven't already but my guess is we
probably have a lot of the same fans
anyway are you ready to get it going I'm
very very prepared
[Music]
but first we start with sriracha you
ready for sriracha yeah sriracha no big
deal definitely not a big deal so when I
watch your videos I'm so fascinated by
the way that you can order off of a
fast-food menu I've never seen anything
like it in all my life oh that's how
small it is
okay 175 please and one of the things
that stands out to me is when you were
doing that fast-food lasagna video and
you just said to the employee at
McDonald's can I get a liter of Big Mac
sauce and she hit you back like yeah
sure pull up to window too like she gets
that kind of request every single day
can I get a liter of Big Mac sauce on
the side she was so nonchalant about it
I think that's just like a stone
teenager working at McDonald's like
whatever I don't care it's gonna pop up
on the computer and someone's gonna
handle that [ __ ] in the kitchen
move your ass along next car but the guy
that came on brought the leader of Big
Mac sauce my boy has son holdin it down
24/7 so whenever I go to McDonald's now
casually and like he happens to see
music oh my gosh what are you here for
is it gonna be crazy I'm like nah I'm
just being fat by myself
it's not work it's just music okay okay
you call me if you ever come take my
number down do you have any other
off-menu things or fast food and menu
hacks that you could recommend to the
people out there think about this you
know how there's like a Taco Bell and a
KFC and they're under the same roof
mm-hmm why can't you ask for a fried
chicken burrito they should be able to
handle this that [ __ ] dumb like why
can't I get you know the KFC fries done
supreme style with cheese and stuff on
it like why can't I do that why can't
there be a taco pizza if it's a Pizza
Taco Bell why can't it be a pizza taco
you know like why is there always got to
be me so I'm just this is a piece of
advice if you work at Taco Bell KFC
combo just make a fried chicken taco do
it for me it's my boy at a petite Taylor
Swift complimenting your beard one time
my entire life of speechless I was an I
heart radio and I'm backstage and you
know people walk by like 50
and Chris Pratt Michael is so cool II
don't like trying to take pictures of
people and then there's like phalanx of
managers people in suits like 50 men and
Susak and in the middle of them towering
above them by like two and a half and
standing like 11 feet tall is like
Taylor Swift and heels this like phalanx
of managers is moving and she's like
kind of in the middle like controlling
them she's like Xerxes in 300 you know
she's practically riding on them exactly
and they're moving her through the back
I see her I wasn't oh my god so just go
Taylor and she stops and then so all the
managers stop and like they all look at
me and she looks at me and she goes
that's a beautiful beard I had her
attention that moment and I could
normally play it cool I'm normally
confident and not this time I I didn't
know whether to be like thanks or huh I
know or cool or it's not the only
beautiful thing or whatever I don't know
what to do you had an opportunity of
small window and I didn't know which of
those things I wanted to say so when she
was like you have a beautiful beard I
was like why and then she just kind of
like turned straight and they kept going
and I was like oh Shh like I am NOT a
high enough power level to even
communicate dude when I went to bed that
night I lay down and obviously I felt
horrible all about it all but uh they
don't know they made her stop made them
all stop just did weeks I'm just
enjoying myself right now it'll change
just like with your show I had so much
fun cooking with you it was so much fun
until the end
same vibe when we hurt ourselves do you
think that some of the appeal of Epic
Meal Time might be that it kind of flies
in the face of the way that food culture
is trending because there's so much of
these like Gwyneth Paltrow goop sort of
dingdong snobby people and I think
sometimes people just might like that
it's a little bit more real that it's a
little bit more primitive that it's a
little bit more visceral with Epic Meal
Time and maybe that might be some of the
appeal do you ever think about that
totally I try and I try and analyze it a
lot and I think you know there has to be
balance to everything
and there was a strong organic vegan
movement Oh bacon cheeseburgers horrible
that you know it birthed epicMealTime in
2010 like you made this
you were so dead set about it being one
way that there just has to be a balance
in the universe a match for Epic Meal
Time came to just counter the scales
because it made the culinary world
approachable to your average Joe because
they'd looked at people like me and like
all this idiots in the kitchen doing it
I should get in the kitchen too like who
says you got anything to get in the
kitchen I like tacos I like pizza I'm
sure I can make both of those and put
them together now it's a fun little
creation that happens in 2010 but now
we're 2016 and we're getting people
tweeting us pictures of their chef
knives tattooed on their forearms or
like I went to culinary school cuz of
Epic Meal Time I'm like great now you
know how to cook better than all of us
I'm not like you got to eat until you
die I'm doing that French attainment
purposes because I am saying get
comfortable around food get comfortable
around cooking and anyone can do it pain
is good we're turning it on or turn into
not Manos there I think this is our
young meat no yeah from t-ball nice you
really lean down thank you Oh guitar
girl I am you've had so many amazing
guests on Epic Meal Time and much like
our show you guys seem to favor the
oddballs so I want to bring up some that
stand out to me and you can just tell me
what you remember about that day just
react to it okay yes sir
I would guess that this might have been
your favorite Epic Meal Time shoot ever
was the time that you made the ostrich
egg sandwich on the tank was that the
greatest day you had doing that with
Arnold Schwarzenegger yes the first
movie I ever saw in theaters was
Terminator 2 I was 5 years old so you
can imagine how blow your mind when
you're 5 and I left there looks like
this is what I want to do in life I'm
like 5 I'm like I want to do movies
movies are the coolest ever like that's
how I got into doing what I'm doing the
first Epic Meal Time episode ever I'm
wearing an almost worst [ __ ] t-shirt
I'm not sure where my armature nah
that's stupid he wouldn't like it no
maybe he'll love it
no what would he want and I'm like Cena
I meant like you know by the end of it I
was like oh hell yeah that's great he's
a kid I like him like yeah I almost wore
my Arnold shirt and then I thought maybe
you think that was weird
do it and now you know I'm chillin we're
chillin how crazy is that he's like you
gotta go swear to god he's like I gotta
go and he hopped in his tank
I'm joking he got his tank is a tank and
he drove away and I was like a [ __ ]
cool let me ask you about a guy that we
had on our show you made the Cinnabons
supreme with a young riff raff what was
that like young riff raff you mean by
young riff raff you mean he was like 88
pounds lighter you know this the guy is
always on right he's always making jokes
joke after joke after joke and I do that
too but then people tend to get like
annoyed of me after like three hours
like riff raff gets better right like he
gets bad riff raff definitely
yeah he's literally like one of the
funniest guys I've spent time with just
listening to him of the things that he
says just [ __ ] crazy
how's my getting pizza cake with Tony
Hawk made pizza cake with Tony Hawk who
got a skateboard actually in the other
room he came to my house and we cooked
something and he was like oh he called
music [ __ ] I left my skateboard I was
like ah sorry he's a cat keep it I'm
like no for real take it I'll take it
music now keep it my favorite thing is
it was like scared like oh cool
skateboard Oh cinema no just Tony Hawk
skateboards good Harley are you just
saying that I would [ __ ] so ready to
tell you got a [ __ ] hot sauce yes so
already know but it's actually good I'm
not gonna lie we spent all day together
talked about it a little bit but I do
want to talk to you about it on our show
because I need some advice you're kind
of YouTube Oh G as some guy who's
networked up who's worked the room and
all those things do you have any advice
for how hot ones can get it to seat at
the table well I think you guys do have
a seat at the table now it's just that
like when I first started you know when
YouTube in 2010 there was probably 15 or
20 channels on are over a million
subscribers now there's like a million
channels with a million subscribers like
now I go to VidCon you know rise to know
everyone and like some kid walks through
the lobby and everyone's like screaming
I like and they're going nuts [ __ ] had
people like oh [ __ ] you don't know Chaz
he's the newest [ __ ] on musically and
I'm like what the [ __ ] are you been
saying to me the seat at the table thing
isn't so important because it's just
better to make your own table
and you know put wings on cutting boards
and make your own [ __ ] copies your
idea right and then [ __ ] the other table
but you can't cause this is actually
literally your table that's my table
don't [ __ ] with it Muruga blood orange
scorpion pepper sauce [ __ ]
Oh left tasty oh no I'm gonna get like
that that happens to me that's tasty at
first but it kind of gets in like a
[ __ ] hate milk and I know I'm gonna
have to turn to his [ __ ] ass so I'm
gonna have to ask you to speak on behalf
of all Canadians some of the biggest
stars in America right now are Canadian
but they spend a lot of time in the
United States and I wonder for Canadians
is it kind of like when a baby Buffalo
gets pet at Yellowstone by a human and
then the entire herd rejects them from
we left to LA for like two years when we
came back there was a lot of like uh you
guys are back now I okay mmm yeah just
didn't work out through there oh we're
like oh yeah mr. hotshot Hollywood and I
got to come to the corner and get bagels
with the rest of us really it's just
like it's like a like a semi like
Montreal specifically a sensitive you
know what I mean
we're not many personalities here and
when people leave much you're off it's
not so bad to go to the stage it's like
how cool he made it he went to the
states like if you go to Toronto it's
like you [ __ ] trading [ __ ] you went
to Toronto it's just another Canadian
city same as here what's wrong with you
Wow now I feel a turning on now they're
bringing it mm-hmm know what kinds of
YouTube comments pissing off the most
you know I even got a person say it to
me in person want someone that they
really know me too
all that foods pretty big waste you know
people are going hungry I know that of
course I know that and I'm already
Jewish so I have a built-in guilt
already no Matt before this even started
I was guilty of something I just felt
guilty
we took a portion of our budget our TV
budget we donated it to feeding America
org you know we mentioned it once at the
end of a TV episode just go check it out
yourselves not to be like this is what
we did we're so good but like I did
something the people that already knows
come to huh people are going hungry who
cares you for saying in my comments
section or any comments section if it's
something you feel you do it get the
[ __ ] off the internet and go down to the
[ __ ] soup kitchen and handle that
[ __ ] I'm with you 100%
internalize that energy and then channel
it into something positive you know what
I feel like you do have an ability to
make change and if it is something that
bothers you
fine go out and make a difference that's
what I hate the useless comments you
know what I mean or when they're like Oh
Harley isn't unfuckable ocher okay I
know
I beat Dietrich College don't laps
around you check out all I had to do he
was the only guy want to because he the
best can you talk a little bit about the
mechanics of eating with a beard like
that because Action Bronson has a whole
like thing that he does I'm trying to
watch anything it and doing it I'm
watching you this whole time you don't
seem to have a plan but your milk is so
good mmm
drink and wrote at the time I'm an
Action Bronson my favorite thing mmm YUM
there's really give me overtime at you a
little bit shovel coal over my shorts
and hey you
my lips are bothering me how that
happens
what's saying about this oh no Action
Bronson not an idiot oh I get
body-slammed off the statement then I
watch I love watching my munchies
you know when he bends down he's eating
he moves his beard and I watch it and
I'm just like we were honest and
convinced he's gonna die on that show
I'm so huge he makes everything look so
tasty and my beard is different my beard
is just stiff like he looks down his
beard falls that's why he pulls that
move I think so my beard is not moving
yeah you know so I need to wash I wash
my beard every day I don't wash my hair
every day but I wash my beard every day
like right now there's milk and hot
sauce in it like that's gross imagine
making out with me some human beings
have chosen to do that in their life I
can't imagine
[Music]
soaking my lips in my own mouth so this
is mad dog 357 357 thousand scovilles it
used to be our hottest sauce and now
it's our second hottest sauce cool for
me thank you that's so cool
this sauce red carpet she's very hot use
their own risk
Scottie way to do it they just want to
touch with my lips I don't know huh
[Music]
before it sucks really tasty that's the
thing about mad dog is it's like if they
didn't make this the hottest sauce ever
it would be a great sauce
but then they put it still tastes good
yeah absolutely it's not burning from
here it's like coming from inside up
[ __ ] up so Montreal consistently ranks
on all these lists as one of the best
bachelor party cities I wonder
first does that ring true to you second
can you give me a Saturday itinerary ah
what did you ask
oh here's what's happening let's cut the
[ __ ] no directive you just flew in
to Montreal yep today yep we're filming
this this is done you're gonna go shower
I'm gonna go shower yep we're gonna come
back here we're gonna do a [ __ ] ton of
drugs call girl hop into an uber yeah
it's gonna go to super sex you're gonna
kiss on boobies you're gonna touch it
they're gonna take your straw they're
gonna put it inside them they're gonna
put it back in your drink you're gonna
mean like I've never experienced
anything like this some strange guys
gonna come out he's gonna give you
powder and using bud put this in your
nose okay a bunch of all that only live
once and then you and I are gonna go to
neuro massage we'll be in separate rooms
they're gonna lie you on the floor onto
an inflatable mattress they're gonna
dump oil on you then two beautiful
Montreal women that don't speak the same
languages you're gonna come out and
there are all their naked bodies all
over yours until you busted your own
bellybutton
Wow then I'm gonna give you a lift back
to the hotel we're gonna tuck you in
give you a high five and be like amen it
was really awesome meeting you remember
Montreal forever
okay I have a suggestion
yeah do this show on ecstasy really yeah
I'm not saying my suggestion is a good
one
I'm just saying you should do that one
day why would that help I don't think it
will I think would be worse so this is
Blair's Megadeth sauce with liquid rage
of course you and I know all about that
because your boys tried to not try to
they did prank Gus and they put the
Blair's Megadeth sauce into the rib rub
and then that's why we're coming undone
the way we are
I'm the tenth wing it's kind of
tradition to dab it with a little extra
a little extra you don't have to if you
don't want to Harley I know you're
pretty blasted out right now but if you
want to you can join me yeah Shawn I'm
gonna make you make me look like a [ __ ]
in my own house that's my guy
okay who the [ __ ] is Blair he's a narc
it's a heat community now but you know
what though all right I think that a
dude you'd have to be like a jerk-off
dude to make something like this like
women are too smart to end up making a
product like this no a woman would never
make a faster design you should wait
you're smart for this
exactly okay very deliberate parley that
qualifies all right Cheers just slow
down for a second till all right we'll
go at your pace my man like I have so
much drool already building are we
designed so strangely humans why would I
start drooling like Oh prepare my brain
is like ah Sh the [ __ ] again you know
the sucks so get wet yeah what primitive
instincts is kicking in here so it in
the face okay are you ready we touch and
we should probably do one of those you
relieve guys
shut off
I really don't want to do this you don't
really have to but I know
if you could have anyone on Epic Meal
Time living or dead who would it be and
what would you make it's like really
trying to get on top of it mentally how
are you feeling
I've been here you gotta like it hump in
here three times before
at Burning Man Woodstock Boo Berry
nothing we talk Harley you made it
through I was a little worried about J
cuz that rib puts it out but you did it
watch me die floor is yours let the
people know what you got going on in
your life mr. Boyd Harley sweatiest
islands in the game
I swear to god I've never sweat from my
eyelids before but I'm sweating up here
follow me on everything I'd hardly plays
youtube.com / part of the more daily
videos Epic Meal Time you already know
it is me and John are gonna tear it up
tonight
[Music]